the jurgen experience we go
uh for people watching at home trying to
sync up we're at 454
453 452 451 450 of the first round
amanda ribes and paige van zandt and
this girl's stalking paige
paige landed a nice kick there
how the [ __ ] did you eat chick-fil-a
[ __ ]
god damn it joe
i don't know i felt bad i didn't know
what he used to eat fish fillets from
mcdonald's 20 years ago when we used to
come home oh yes
if i'm uh if i'm stoned i'll still eat
those no you don't i like fish fillets
oh my gosh
oh my god last time i even had a
migraine headache for two days
it's barely fish it's some things that
fish swam by oh my god
look at this page oh reba's got her down
in side control that's not good
that's not good she's got her arm
trapped too in that scarf hold
that's a that's an uncomfortable
position and paige is trying to hold her
in place
by by gripping her arms like that she's
already cut
but that's all she has to do reba's all
she has to do is fish her arm through
see her right arm fish it arm through
see she's trying to do that but paige
got it tight
if she could figure out how to fish her
arm through and clamp her heads together
that's a legit submission man oh look at
this paige is about to take her back
look at this look at this
[Music]
it's uh it's up against the cage if she
was in a better position she might
actually be able to take her back from
here but it's
it's hard when you're up against the
cage like that it's hard to maneuver
so amanda rivas has some blood coming
out of her nose yeah
see but if rebus can get her arm through
oh look at that paige is gonna take her
back
oh [ __ ] she took a chance that oh rebus
is going to take her back
wow that was slick that was slick armbar
armbar oh paige is in real trouble here
that was so slick man see this is the
same thing like she wants to flip her
over but the cage is where she wants to
tuck her
she might still get it she might get it
right from there she might get it right
oh she's going to get it right from
there
paige has got to tap you can't she can't
break her arm yep tap tap tap she's
tapping
that's it man that's
she's okay good